in ten days time to cover right get  ready  oh sorry for the ride oh sorry of this  summer not cool  come on man one time please  laughs we're gonna call you antonio  banderas admin and the wasp rated PG 13  July 6th  I just have one question  when cap needed help if I'd asked you  would you have come I guess we'll never  know but if you had you'd have never  been caught  [Music]  I do some dumb things and the people I  love the most they pay the price thanks  to you we had to run  [Music]  we're still running let's go  [Music]  maybe you just need someone watching  your back  linked a partner  hold on you gave her wings and blasters  so I take it you didn't have that tech  available for me no I did  you  you